je rentre à demain matin où tu vois je
dors chez suzy ce soir
c'est nouveau la fiche dans le journal
ils appellent l'attrapeur j'aime pas que
tu l'appelles comme ça tu crois quand
même parce que les autres raconte parce
qu'ils peuvent attendre il enlève pas
vraiment ce qu'ils sont
quel ordre de wii super formidable je
vous ai dis regarde moi ça
tu peux me donner mon chapeau
merci jeunes âmes je suis magicien
amateurs
vous avez des ballons noirs là bas si tu
veux je te fais un tour de magie
j'ai quelque chose à vous annoncer l'un
de nos élèves green et blake a été
kidnappé et si je pouvais aider la
police à retrouver finesse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ils marchent pas
il marchait déjà pas quand j'étais petit
je l aurais je vous ai corps ferez le
visage celui ci
j'ai rêvé de lui et ce qui se passait
dans ton rêve il se faisait enlever un
homme avec des ballons noirs la police
n'a jamais révélé ce détail
e
halo ne raccroche pas sais qui
tu nous connais tous
tu vas sortir baissé
s'il vous plaît faites que m a dit tu
regardes le maire en face de toi j'ai
arraché un câble sur toute la longueur
ya un cap makoun sur la porte d'entrée
tu te souviens du code
jeu les graver sur le mur s'est fait mal
tout
comme la porte la grille je reconnais
qu'il avait vu plusieurs fois en règle
m
tu vas te servir d'une arme je lève le
combiné un pas en arrière et tu feras
tu vois ce que tu m'as fait taire et
laisser vous rappelle que je t'avais dit
qu'à un moment il faudrait que
j'apprenne à me défendre ces mamans
c'est ma chance